Hello, I'm the Nostalgia Critic. I remember it so you don't have to.
Well...
Christmas is over, Santa has come, and...
I guess I got a little bit of a post-Christmas blues. I mean...
12 months waiting, weeks upon weeks of hoping for the world's greatest Christmas gifts, and what did I get?
A Nintendo Wii entertainment system, two fully-functional controllers, the latest edition of Super Smash Bros. Brawl...
and no Mario Kart?
Suck my candy cane, Santa! That was the cream of the yuletide crop, and you knew it!
Instead, what did I get in my stocking?
A holly, jolly dose of BULLSHIT known as "Jingle All the Way"'.
The first and, thank God, only Christmas film to star international punch line Arnold Schwarzenegger.
And since I got the post-Christmas blues, you're gonna share this hunk of stinking yellow snow with me.
So! Grab your vomit bags and get ready to find out
oh what fun it is to ride in a horse-shit-spewing fuck ride like this one!
Let's take a look.
So, it starts out with a show called "Turbo Man".
I'd say it's like Power Rangers for younger kids, but it's more like Power Rangers for retarded kids.
I mean, I think this is the film's first big hole:
No normal, functioning kid would actually watch this intergalactic space crap.
I mean, seriously, what kid would watch a show with a flying, hunchback saber tooth Care Bear in it?
Well, apparently, this kid would: a little boy named Jamie played by Jake Lloyd.
Jake Lloyd. Hmm. Now, where do I know that name?
[Dun dun DUNNN!!!]
Oh! Ah! AHHH!!!
[Glass breaks]
[Critic screams while falling]
[Thud]
My god, what a tall building!
He's upset because his father is a workaholic played by Arnold Schwarzenegger.
I'd just be upset if my father was Arnold Schwarzenegger.
The last straw is when Arnold misses his son's karate graduation.
Arnold tries to make it but is caught in traffic and is also stopped by the world's oldest policeman.
Oh, well, if you're in a [thick accent] "hur-ray".
Arnold tries to "hur-ray" up but ultimately misses the ceremony.
Thanks... Arnold. I never would have figured that out if you didn't say something.
What is this? Movies for the blind?
[As Arnold Schwarzenegger]
"I'm walking down the hallway. I stop to catch my breath.
"I look into an empty room with a janitor to emphasize what a douche bag I am."
Things don't get much better when his next-door-neighbor, played by Phil Hartman, starts becoming more fatherly than he does.
{Sorry you missed the karate class today, but don't worry. I got it all on video for ya.}
[As Phil Hartman]
"Hi. I'm Troy McClure!
"You may remember me from such horrible Christmas classics as 'Here Comes Stephen Segal'...
'Frosty the Van Damme', and 'The Stalone Who Stole Christmas'!"
Arnold tries to apologize to his son, but Jamie's heart has been broken too many times for him to listen.
[As Arnold Schwarzenegger]
"You will come to me, Jaime! Or I will destroy you!
"BLAAAGH!"
[Karate yells]
And this guy was a multi-million-dollar action star.
Life is stupid.
But Arnold, still feeling bad, tries to find a way to make it up to his son.
[As Jake Lloyd]
"Well, I've always wanted to ruin a Star Wars Movie."
{I want the Turbo Man action figure with the arms and legs that move, and the boomerang shooter, and the rockin', roaring jetpack...}
{Johnny's gonna get one, and so is everybody else I know! Whoever doesn't is gonna be a real loser.}
Aw! Materialism brings everybody together. That's what Christmas is all about!
There's only one problem, though: Arnold doesn't have the doll.
I love how the wife isn't even really acting here.
She's just preparing for the world's most unconvincing head duck for the camera.
She does it so fast, I wonder if she hits her head on the sink.
[BAM!]
[Forceful exhale]
That's gonna hurt.
I also love this over-the-top expression that Arnold gives that looks like the cliff hanger of a horrible 80s sitcom.
"Uh oh! How's Arnold gonna get out of this one?
"Will he have time to get the gift? Or will the most unpractical and implausible of hi-jinks ensue?
"Tune in next time when Master-Piece-Of-Shit Theater continues!"
We find out, though, that while Arnold has to get the doll,
he might miss the Christmas parade that they always go to. But Arnold reassures his son.
Am I the only one who thinks this touching moment looks relatively threatening?
[Deep, demonic voice]
"I promise."
[As Arnold Schwarzenegger]
"I will eat you, Jamie!"
[Vicious growling]
While waiting in line at the toy store, he comes across a mailman who's looking for the same toy,
played by the thankfully underappreciated Sinbad.
{and then they sit there and use subliminal messages to suck your children's minds out!}
If you were somehow blessed with not remembering this early-90s rape of comedy,
consider that your own personal Chrstimas gift.
Oh, okay, he's not that bad, but he does seem to have this unique talent of just sucking the comedy out of a scene.
Even if there's no comedy to be found.
{And then, they sit there and make your kid feel like garbage if you, the father, who's workin' 24/7 delivering mail}
{so you can make an alimony payment to a woman that slept with everybody at the post office but me!}
You hear that lack of joy and laughter that most people hear when certain comedians are around?
THAT... is the power of Sinbad.
They try to go and get the doll, but it turns out the store is all out.
[Wheezing laughter]
[Loud laughter]
"And I think I'm having a psychotic episode. Duh!"
[Goofy chuckling]
That's the Arnold we all know and love! Now squash their heads like grapefruit!
Pussy!
He spots someone driving away with it,
but, unfortunately, the driver recognizes Schwarzenegger and correctly steps on the gas.
Arnold goes from store to store, trying to find a Turbo Man, but comes out empty-handed.
He takes his frustration out on a cardboard cutout as it's the only performance that's more wooden than his.
[As Arnold Schwarzenegger]
"I will destroy you, cardboard!"
[Growling and yelling]
As if we didn't have enough annoying performances, Phil Hartman comes in again to put the moves on Arnold's wife.
{It's Christmas Eve and you're slaving over a hot stove. Is this the Mom of the Year or what?}
[As Phil Hartman]
"You know I'm the antagonist in this picture because
"all poorly-written antagonists always talk in a slimy,  over-the-top voice."
[Creepy groaning]
Things get even worse when Arnold tries to call his wife and instead gets Nasty McJackass on the line.
[As Arnold Schwarzenegger]
"You stay away from my wife! Or I'll eat you!"
"You stay away from my cookies!"
"Stay away from my wife, stay way from my cookies, and stay away from my wife's cookies!
"OR I DESTROY YOU!"
[Stammers]
[Dial tone]
"COOKIIIIIIIES!!!"
Oh, good! For a second there, I started tolerating the art of film-making.
[Laughing]
Yeah, except, uh, he's successful and you're not.
God!
At the store, unfortunately, they hand out colored balls that will take place in a drawing
that will decide who gets the toy and who doesn't.
{If you're not one of the lucky few, we have PLENTY of Turbo Man's faithful pet tiger, Booster, in stock.}
[As Arnold Schwarzenegger]
"Fuck Booster! Give me the Turbo Man, you girly man!"
Things get ugly when the mob breaks out and Sinbad steals the ball away from Arnold.
[As Arnold Schwarzenegger]
"Destroy him! Destroy him then eat him!"
Unfortunately, the ball moves a lot like Flubber as it keeps getting higher and higher the more times it bounces around.
It falls into the hands of a...
genderly undefinable child... as Arnold roams through the mall's playground to get it back.
[As Arnold Schwarzenegger]
"Out of my way, children! Or I eat you! I eat you all!"
Girl! That's what it was.
Fortunately, more people recognize Arnold and give him the proper greeting that he's used to...
which still means no Turbo man, but hope comes in the shape of a Belushi.
Oh, hey! A gay joke in a children's film. Merry Christmas.
He tells him where he can get a Turbo Man at this sort of underground, disgruntled Santa workshop
where they sell hard-to-find toys at outrageous prices.
But Arnold is given a false product as he tries to escape the workshop without paying.
But this is harder than it seems as Arnold's confronted by dozens of Santas,
killer elves, and even a ninja that uses candy canes as nunchucks.
Ladies and gentlemen, welcome to Idiot Land!
Where nothing is too ridiculous or too insulting to anyone's intelligence.
Want to see Arnold fight homicidal Santa Clauses with a candy cane?
Nothing is too hard for us in Idiot Land.
Want to see a musclebound giant hit a little person across the room?
In the realms of Idiot Land, anything is possible.
Idiot Land. It's full of...
IDIOTS!
So Arnold finally escapes and calls his son to let him know the bad news that not only did he not get the doll,
but he probably won't be able to make it to the parade.
[As Jake Lloyd]
"Yay! I'm acting!"
"Well, that just puckers my lips!"
[Calmly]
Gee, that wasn't over-dramatic.
[As Rita Wilson]
"Damn you."
[Phone rings]
"Hello?"
"My pizza's gonna be late?"
"Damn you."
Because the pits of Hell decided we haven't suffered enough, we get ANOTHER appearance by Sinbad
as he tries to patch things up with Arnold once more.
Gee, would you be so kind as to, uh, NOT reenact it for us?
Oh... God, I hate you.
[As Rita Wilson]
"Damn you. Damn you!"
Wondering how much he's getting paid for this movie,
Arnold suddenly looks over and imagines his son having a very similar future.
[As Arnold Schwarzenegger]
"Dear God! My son is going to grow up to be an unsuccessful, unfunny black man!"
But the chase continues as they rush into a radio station that apparently gives out the Turbo Man to anyone who can answer a holiday question.
But that turns out to be bogus, too.
So the police come in, thank God, to try and take him away.
But Sinbad tries to get out of it by taking one of his packages and pretending it's a bomb.
[Gentlemen... we've been duped.}
[Sighs of relief]
[Explosion]
[Chuckling]
That was actually kinda funny.
[Laughing]
This movie actually had a funny moment in it!
Look! I'm smiling! I'm actually smiling!
[Laughing harder]
This movie actually had a really funny scene!
[Laughing]
[Cops coughing]
[Forced laughter]
No. No, you're ruining the joke! Don't ruin the one funny scene you have in this movie!
[Insane laughter turns into yelling]
You did it! You actually did it!
You ruined the only funny joke in the movie, you jingle balls of ass!
DAMN YOU! DAMN YOU ALL TO HELL!
[Sobbing]
Arnold stoops to the ultimate low as he tries to steal a Turbo Man from Phil Hartman's house.
But, luckily, a psychotic, blood-hungry reindeer hunts him down to make sure he doesn't get away with it.
Hey, don't look at me! I didn't write it.
His wife finally decides to take her son to the parade, leaving Arnold behind.
Arnold searches for the appropriate response.
Oh, it turns out the reindeer is still hungry for Austrian meat.
[Groans in pain]
Oh, good. What do you think the big, witty Schwarzenegger line is gonna be?
[Stammers]
What? That's all you got?
Come on! You're Arnold Schwarzenegger! You're a professional at this!
Come on! There's a million better witty lines you could say, like...
Or...
Or, if you're really desperate...
Just show us that you're trying!
So they show up to the parade of the only affordable copyrighted characters they could get,
where Arnold tries one more time to set things right.
Here, he's mistaken for a stuntman/actor.
Isn't he already?
Where he's slipped into - here's a big shocker - a Turbo Man outfit.
I guess it figures. Arnold already resembles an inanimate object that shouts nothing but corny catchphrases.
[Arnold]
[Man in Booster suit]
Eww. That's an image: Arnold Schwarzenegger as Mary Poppins.
Eww! Deleted!
Arnold also partakes in, get this,
a special part of the parade where he hands out a Turbo Man doll to a special child in the audience.
Gee. I wonder who it could be.
[Amplified]
[As Jake Lloyd]
"And he has a thick, Austrian accent for some reason."
So Jamie marches up there and collects his prize and has the greatest Christmas Day ever.
Right. Yeah. I know the routine. Yeah.
I'm gonna say something like, "Well, that wasn't as bad as I thought it would be.
"I mean it was bad, but it wasn't horrible."
And then? The movie's gonna surprise me with the shittiest part of the entire film!
Well, I'm not gonna fall for it. Nope.
I'm betting you anything that this is not the end of the movie.
Nope. Nope. Not the end. Not the end.
Really?
No surprises, or anything?
No last-minute climax? No cheasy, over-the-top special effects?
Really?
Okay. Alright. I mean...
It's true. It wasn't as bad as I thought it would be.
I mean it was bad, but not nearly as horrible as--
[Female host]
FUCK YOU, MOVIE! FUCK YOU! FUCK YOU! FUCK YOU! FUCK YOU! FUCK YOU! FUCK YOU!
So Sinbad comes in, dressed up as Turbo Man's arch nemesis, the Green Dildo.
Yes, listen to the person dressed up as Turbo Man. He's not taking anything too far.
So the boy runs away with the doll as Sinbad tries to get it from him.
Everybody just applauds as they assume this is all just part of the act.
No argument here.
[What'ya gonna do now, kid?!}
[As Arnold Schwarzenegger]
"That's right, Jamie! Kick him in the balls! They are man's greatest design flaw!"
So Jamie actually climbs up a tall building all because he can't give away his beloved, fucking Turbo Man.
[As Jake Lloyd]
"I would sooner die than part with my commercial piece of plastic!"
Okay, kid. There's liking a toy, and then there's insanely obsessing over a toy!
I mean, your life isn't worth it. Just give him the damn plushie, you little moron!
By the way, has anyone noticed that this is the longest stopped-parade stunt in the history of implausibility?
"Well, at the rate this parade is going, Santa should float by in roughly...
"12 hours."
[Screaming]
So let me get this straight...
A parade that can barely afford what looks like two balloons and only a few copyrighted characters
can afford a fully-functional rocket pack that even NASA couldn't perfect yet?
Is there a name for all that's wrong with these writers?!
So he's flying through the city and...
uh... uh...
I... uh...
[Stammering]
Okay. Alright.
Ladies and gentlemen...
the film just gave up.
It clearly doesn't care about the story narrative or making any semblance of logical sense, so they just said...
"Fuck it", and started showing amusing images that will hopefully entertain your kids.
Well, you know what they say:
"If you can't beat 'em, join 'em."
[Nonsensical music starts]
Uh oh! It looks like Jamie is slipping!
[As Arnold Schwarzenegger]
"Jamie! No! I will have no one to eat for later!"
[Snarling]
So, of course, Arnold rescues the boy and saves the day.
[As Jake Lloyd]
"You're much better than that other overbuilt, Austrian guy that I look up to!"
{I wish that Dad could have been here, ya know. See me fly and all. But he didn't come.}
[As Jake Lloyd]
"Yes! Do tell, strange, musclebound, big-teethed,
"square-jawed, Austrian-accented He Man who isn't in any way my father!"
[Stammering]
WHAAA-?
I haven't been this shocked since I found out the secret to living a long-lasting life...
was breathing!
But wait. What's little Jamie up to?
[As Sinbad]
"As soon as I'm done serving five to twenty."
[Chuckles]
[As Jake Lloyd]
"I don't care that you tried to savagely kill me
"just to get your hands on a children's possession to satisfy your own sense of self worth."
"For me, that's what Christmas is all about!"
[As Jake Lloyd]
"A Turbo Man who neglects me and puts his work before anything else!"
[As Arnold Schwarzenegger]
"So long, Jaime. I'm off to neglect you some more."
Wow... I can safely say that we've all learned absolutely nothing.
Well, maybe one thing: "JINGLE ALL THE WAY" CAN JINGLE ALL THE WAY TO HELL!
THIS IS THE WORST CHRISTMAS GIFT SINCE DONALD TRUMP'S TOUPEE!
It goes against everything that Christmas is about, gets soaked up in a festering ball of commercialism,
and actually has the balls to somehow get Arnold Schwarzenegger and Sinbad in there!
So, Santa, for giving me such a good gift this year, I have just one thing to say to you:
You better watch out. You better not cry.
You better not pout. I'm telling you why.
THE NOSTALGIC CRITIC IS COMING TO YOUR HOME, BITCH!
I'M RIP-ROARING PISSED! I REMEMBER IT SO YOU DON'T HAVE TO!
[Bell ringing]
Ho ho ho!
[Knock at door, door opens]
Ho, ho...
HOOOOO!!!
[Gunshot]
AND A HAPPY NEW YEAR!
Reviewed by donald piper. ENJOY!!